ceci est un couloir de métro ou du moins
sa représentation un moyen de comprendre
les mouvements de foule avec trajectoire
la mobilité se fait exposition
l'objectif
voilà il est au moins double c'est à
dire pouvoir identifier des groupes de
citoyens et c'est à dire partir de leurs
questionnements
plutôt que de faire voilà des
injonctions à la nécessité de réfléchir
sur une thématique de telle ou telle
façon non là on part vraiment de la base
c'est à dire des questionnements propre
des gens le deuxième intérêt c'est de
pouvoir présenter cette exposition et
les contenus qui ont été réalisés à des
groupes de scolaires à du grand public
voilà toujours en ile de france
l'exposition est divisée en trois pôles
individuels collectifs et la planète
elle entre dans le projet questions de
sciences au jeu sociétés de la région
ile de france
quand on parle de trajectoire et
mobilité on a l'impression que on va
parler uniquement de voitures dans cette
moyenne transports et tout qu'est ce
qu'on peut en faire de cette de cette
exposition c'est finalement une
réflexion est peut-être un changement
dans nos habitudes de mobilité en
particulier je pense à l'heure actuelle
tout l'écologie et puis la sauvegarde de
la planète est quand même très
importante la mobilité c'est transversal
c'est universel mais ça se traduit avec
dédé des outils des engins des systèmes
différents
selon nos situations selon les trajets
qu'on veut faire et donc cette
exposition trajectoire elle essaye de
nous montrer toute cette diversité et
tous les liens qu'on peut avoir entre
une mobilité locale urbaine quotidienne
démoli d'immobilité de tourisme conçu
par huit associations et un comité
scientifique
l'exposition est accessible à tout
public à partir de 6 ans un moyen de
prendre du recul sur le quotidien de se
détacher de ses habitudes